nos preguntan cuántas tasas hay en tres
y medio galones para lo cual estaría
padre saber cuántas tasas hay en un
galón así que hagamos un pequeño repaso
de tasas cuartas pintas y galones vale
aquí tengo un dibujo este buque este
dibujo de aquí este cubo representa un
galón vamos a hablar acerca de algunas
conversiones déjame empezar con cuartas
resulta que en cada galón tenemos cuatro
cuartas o sea si el galón lo partimos en
cuatro partes iguales ésta está esta y
ésta cada una de esas es una cuarta le
voy a poner por aquí una cuarta y por lo
tanto tenemos la conversión cuatro
cuartas cuatro cuartas
por galón por galón galo
muy bien ahora si agarramos una de esas
cuartas por ejemplo esta de acá y la
partimos a la mitad lo que obtenemos
ahora es una pinta esto de aquí sería
una tinta bueno estoy aquí sería una
pinta sale una pinta entonces esa es
nuestra segunda conversión aquí le puse
un igual no sé por qué déjame borrarlo
la segunda conversión sería que tenemos
dos pintas dos dos pintas pintas
en cada cuarto en cada cuarto cual
cuarta sale entonces tomamos tomamos una
cuarta la partimos en dos eso de ahí nos
da una pinta lo de abajo es una pinta y
lo de arriba también y si esta pinta de
arriba la partimos una vez más en dos
entonces ahora lo que obtenemos es una
taza eso de ahí sería una taza lo que
está marcado en rojo vale entonces la
última conversión es que es que tenemos
dos tazas dos tazas en cada pinta en
cada pinta pinta muy bien con esta
información ya podemos determinar
cuántas tazas hay en un galón
simplemente lo convertimos pues o sea
imagínate que tenemos un galón y
queremos determinar cuántas tazas hay
entonces lo que podemos hacer es empezar
con cuartos por galón y multiplicarlo
por pintas por cuarta es decir podemos
tomar esta equivalencia cuatro cuartos
por galón cuatro cuartas
por galón galón y está multiplicarla por
esta de acá por
por dos pintas pintas
por cuarta por cuarta cuarta y eso lo
que nos va a dar es lo siguiente las
cuartas se van a cancelar con las
cuartas cuatro por dos nos va a quedar
ocho nos va a quedar ocho y por lo tanto
nos va a quedar en unidades pintas por
galón entonces tenemos ocho pintas
pintas
pintas en cada galón en cada galón muy
bien eso es totalmente lógico verdad si
tenemos cuatro cuartos por cada galón y
hay dos pintas en cada en cada cuarto
entonces pues hay ocho pintas en cada
galón dos por cuatro es ocho pero
imagínate que ahora queremos pasar a
tasas entonces lo que tendríamos que
hacer ahora es multiplicar por esta tasa
de cambio de aquí entonces nos quedaría
por dos tazas por pinta tasas por pinta
y la idea de multiplicar multiplicar por
esta tasa es que ahora se eliminen las
pintas acá la tenemos en el numerador
acá en el denominador por lo tanto
pintas se va con pintas y finalmente nos
queda nos queda la equivalencia que nos
interesa déjame tomar el amarillo que va
a ser 16 tazas por galón 16 tazas tazas
por galón y galón muy bien y eso está
padrísimo ya tenemos en un galón cuántas
tazas hay pero lo que nos preguntan aquí
es cuántas tazas hay en tres y medio
galones no en un galón así que déjame
poner esto
tres y medio galones por acá tres y
medio galones galones galones y antes de
hacer la conversión de unidades déjame
pasar este número mixto a una fracción
porque no me gusta trabajar con números
mixtos bueno tres y medio son siete
medios verdad si hacemos siete entre dos
nos queda tres y sobra uno tres y medio
es lo mismo que siete medios entonces
tres y medio galones son siete medios de
galón los siete medios galones galones y
ahora si podemos utilizar esta tasa de
acá para pasar a tasas o sea esta razón
de cambio para pasar a tasas entonces
aquí tendríamos que multiplicar por 16
tazas tasas por galón galón sale una vez
más la idea es que aquí tenemos galones
y queremos cancelar los entonces hay que
ponerlos en el denominador y queremos
que nos quede tasas en el numerador
entonces por eso usamos esta esta razón
de conversión vale bueno entonces
galones se cancela con galones y nos
queda 7 por 16 entre 2
esto de aquí es igual a haber 7 por 16
no mejor primero hacemos 16 entre 2 16
entre 12 8 así que nos queda 7 por 8 o
sea 56 56 tazas vale entonces esto lo
que nos dice es que en tres y medio
galones hay 56 tazas y siempre es bueno
verificar que todo tenga sentido si
tiene sentido que sean muchas tasas pues
sí como la tasa es una unidad mucho más
pequeña que un galón
tiene sentido que tres y medio galones
sean muchas muchas más tazas